what do you think is going to happen
with Florida because Florida is very
unpredictable you say you like that you
it appealed to you for me that was one
of the things that I wasn't sure about
as you know I was deciding between many
of those States I was like do I go to
Tennessee do I go to Texas uh do I come
to Florida and I just said you know I
think Florida is is strong under under
DeSantis I think he's done a fantastic
job but if it's not to Santas I don't
know Florida is very unpredictable in
presidential elections and things of
that nature so what do you think happens
I want to ask you first do you think
DeSantis is going to run president yes
absolutely okay do you think Trump is
going to run and they're going to both
be on the stage together
if nothing happens here with whatever
they're trying to do well the
shenanigans he's also going to run okay
that's a whole separate we'll get to
that in a second what happens to Florida
if DeSantis set say DeSantis ran let's
say to Santos wins do you have any
concerns about Florida going very blue
of course you always have that concern
of going blue very blue I don't know
blue absolutely right because you're
going to have people that are going to
go and try to Target a couple different
states they're targeting Texas as well
though they're targeting a lot of these
red States they know Target Texas is an
enemy and right now in a lot of
different markets in Texas if you go to
Austin right now you won't feel like
you're in Texas yeah that's Austin's not
Texas Austin's homelessness homelessness
is up you know in the streets it's not
like what you think it is yeah they have
a couple nice areas that you go to but
they're taking a hit Houston's you know
going they're not the third largest city
in America 2.8 million they just passed
up Chicago two three years ago so
Houston's going to be a very powerful
City some are saying it's going to be
the biggest city in America in the next
you know 40 50 years by 20 100 and
economists said by 2100 Houston will be
the largest city in America so is there
that risk in this state you live in yes
okay but let me ask the question a
different way what's the likelihood of
California having a true Conservative
Republican governor the next four years
never not happening okay but give me the
chances zero zero to a hundred
zero let's say one percent point one
okay I'll be generous what's the chances
of us having an AOC governor in the
State of Florida no that's not happening
either so if I'm gonna deal with a
liberal I'm okay but I'm not gonna deal
with a with a radical I'm not gonna deal
with a radical I don't have a I voted
for I'm a Bill Clinton you know I don't
have a problem being with somebody that
understands that economy is critical
leave the business owner alone sure you
want to talk about some of the other
stuff fine but for the most part I the
chances of us having a Conservative
Republican conservative governor in
California is one percent the chance of
having a conservative Governor here over
the next four years four or five times
is a lot higher I'm going to take this
risk over the other one I saw an
exchange that was interesting the other
day between
um our friend Dave Rubin and Megan Kelly
and they were I don't know if you saw
this one they were talking about Trump
voters and Dave Rubin I I believe was of
the opinion that regardless even if
Trump and DeSantis get on the stage the
voters were coalesce behind whoever gets
the nomination and Megan Kelly was
essentially saying the Trump voters are
not going to go for DeSantis they will
not leave Trump and if they believe that
this is Trump's turn that he was denied
last time
um and that it's not to stand his turn
even though they like what DeSantis is
doing in Florida they're not going to
get behind DeSantis they are Trump
loyalists to the end I think about I'm
back and forth on the one hand I think
that it would be good for both
candidates to get on the debate stage
and may the best man win honestly it's
very good for them to have to kind of go
at it like that on the other hand I'm a
little bit concerned about the way Trump
will handle that debate stage because if
he goes after DeSantis the way he goes
after a leftist I don't think that's
going to play so well and I don't know
that he has that type of discipline to
really understand that it's a different
game yeah so here's here's what I think
there's a couple things so take Trump's
uh following and let's break it down in
different types of people
it what percentage of his following is
kind of like sitting there saying look
you had a great run I loved it but it's
time to move on what percentage you
think it is it's got to be a percentage
what do you think I think there's I
think there's probably for me about half
honestly I think I know that it's he's
got too much baggage I don't disagree
let's take the other half of the other
half that's there
what do they need if they had to choose
between
a not voting because they got to show up
right if they had to choose between not
voting or
so sucking their pride you know just
swallowing their pride and saying you
know what I'm gonna vote for DeSantis
what percentage the other have you think
is willing to do whatever they can for
another bite no another person together
so you got 50 that's what Trump does if
Trump throws his support behind a
sandwich they go but nobody he says
don't vote for that's what I'm saying
say they don't no I think it's a
percentage you think half is I think a
lot not half I think about
25 of them we're on the same page yeah
so so the point I'm trying to make is
the fact that it's crazy I know which
was so I think 50 percent is gonna leave
no matter what and they felt they've had
a good run but they're leaving okay the
other 25 I think is gonna say there's no
way in the world I'm going another four
years with Biden or Kamal or you know
new summer whoever's going to be right
yeah the other 25 which is the most
important is gonna be for Trump to come
out and say hey let's get behind the
scientist and let's do this I don't know
if they'll do that the chances of him
doing that will come down to one thing
it's gonna sound weird it's going to
come down to how Newsome handles Trump
because if Newsom if not Newsom how
DeSantis handles Trump if DeSantis comes
out and he tries to troll Trump like
Trump is going to troll him if he does
that forget it I think Trump's going to
be remembering every one of those words
and he's not going to endorse him yeah
but if I think the scientist comes out
and takes it from a standpoint of I
remember when President Trump endorsed
me I was supportive of it I remember
when this I remember when that and I
think the scientist is
capable enough of delivering his message
without offending Trump and still
winning votes for Trump to say fine you
gave me respect because that's what's
very important to Trump you gave me
respect I say we go vote for him and I
think it's going to be Newsome that's
who you think's gonna I mean it's not
going to be Biden oh no he has no idea
who he is I think I think look this is
there's there's I think it's gonna be
new some no matter what I think Newsom
is a superstar for the left you may not
like him but he's a total Superstar for
those guys I think uh you know I think
Mark Cuban this is his season he's about
to step away from uh the show Shark Tank
I think he's stepping away for going out
there and hiring the best Consultants to
prep him for all the topics foreign all
that stuff I'm not telling you it's a
good cat I'm just telling you I think if
he's ever gonna run now is the time to
run it uh I think Michelle if they're
able to get Michelle to choose to get in
I think she's a force to be reckoned
with I just don't know if they want that
life or not I don't know if they want to
do 16 years of that right at this phase
now their girls are getting older the
next phase is going to come grandma
grandpa do they really want to do that
right I don't know they got an
incredible life but if Michelle runs
it's a real threat Newsome the right has
an Insider that can give a lot of
insight her name is Kimberly there's a
lot of information that she can give to
their side about Newsome uh and how to
get under his skin but I think it's
going to be a dog fight if Michelle
Obama runs Newsome is a gift to DeSantis
I mean just the lockdown everybody left
California to go to Florida everyone my
whole building is from New York and Los
Angeles right now I'm you know I'm in
Fort Lauderdale so I think that's a gift
I I don't get his appeal I think he's
very programmed and I think he's he's
available I don't I think he has a I
think he's somebody that you're going to
stick on a debate stage and you're going
to be very surprised that that he can't
go off script well
never underestimate the power of a
spinner
these guys are professional it's not
going to do well with a DeSantis I don't
know about a trump I think Trump would
be hysterical that's the thing you know
you think about Trump that really
appeals to people he is I mean you could
just get your popcorn extra butter sit
there and it's that Hillary stuff oh it
was just I re-watched it now you'd be in
jail that line is gonna go into history
right he was right and she should have
been in jail frankly if you want to
watch the full episode you're going to
click right here and if you want to ask
me a question one on one you want to do
a one-on-one FaceTime with a group of
your friends whatever you want you need
to download manect right now click right
here and let's get talking
thank you